that I noticed is how he really locked
in on the costume designer the moment he
saw her he hunted her down tortured her
and carved some very female insults into
her flesh so does this mean that art has
a problem with women in particular is he
less the Michael Myers of his generation
and more the Elliot Roger I don't know
if there's enough evidence to say for
sure but it sure seems like it based on
these first couple of appearances he has
a tendency to Target women and just kill
the men that get in the way Michael
Myers is very much the same way going
after Lorie Strode Jamie Lloyd Caris
stro and Allison Nelson as his main
targets throughout the years but also
stabbing anyone else who gets in his way
male or female art would continue to
primarily Target female victims going
forward but that's also most horror
movies so this text carving into the
costume designer is probably the
strongest evidence we have what is clear
is that with ar the clown your best bet
is to expect the unexpected this is
especially true when he makes his first
appearance outside the VHS tape and in
the real
world